it was so moving to me
this experience has been something
unbelievable
william shatner gets emotional i'm going
to cry you're going to watch a grown man
cry after becoming the oldest person to
travel to space with jeff bezos's blue
origin what you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can imagine
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just
it's extraordinary
on wednesday the 90 year old star trek
star went up with blue origin the
company founded by jeff bezos as one of
four passengers on board the new shepard
ns18 ship
i'm going up into space
i don't know how many people who can say
that
it's life-changing in its way
not because of the
aerial adventure but because of the
people i'm meeting and talking about i'm
glad to be here
shatner and the other passengers delayed
their trip for a day due to high winds
in texas where the spaceship took off
from and while bezos wasn't on this trip
he did greet the astronauts and closed
the hatch before the vessel took flight
the foursome safely returned to earth
after just a few minutes in space and
bezos was right there to open the hatch
to welcome the crew back to earth
i hope i never recover from this i hope
that i can
maintain what i feel now i don't want to
lose it before taking flight shatner
opened up about his upcoming journey in
a promotional video
i shall be entranced
by the view of space
[Music]
i want to look at that orb
and appreciate its beauty and its
tenacity
and it looks like there's a great
curiosity
about this fictional character
captain kirk going into space
so let's go along with it and enjoy the
ride
and before his trip out of this world
hoda copy shared her thoughts about the
whole thing with e.t i'm kind of
freaking out a little bit captain kirk
is scared he told us he said he was
nervous he just wants to come down
that's all he said i cannot wait to hear
his interview when he comes down because
he is going to be i mean what a chapter
we've had him on our show many times he
is a personality plus plus plus the guy
is fun to be around and i can't wait to
hear what he has to say i know the
successful trip follows the company's
first human flight in july on board that
inaugural flight was bezos himself and
his brother mark along with wally funk
and oliver damon who were at the time
the oldest and youngest people to ever
fly in space when you get into space and
you can see the earth's atmosphere
it's so thin and fragile looking so we
do have to take care of this planet but
back to shatner this isn't the first
time the acting legend has proved he's a
true thrill seeker back in july he
opened up to et about his shark diving
adventure which was captured during what
else discovery channel shark week why
was it important for you to attempt to
overcome that fear of sharks i've done a
lot of things that have been very
dangerous
uh only later that i realized oh my god
i could have died a horrible death i
look back and i think that was really
foolish
because
after all these years of doing stunts
and not doing stunts the people who got
hurt were the stuntmen but the actor me
i don't get hurt so when i go into all
these dangerous situations i'm thinking
you know i won't get hurt you don't get
hurt when you're filming
[Music]
you